[Music]
connecting cops with the community that
is the goal of several events that are
happening around las vegas right now for
national night out arko mana is live in
the northeast valley by lake mead
boulevard and christie lane with a look
at what's happening there orco
well denise national night out is just
getting started and a lot of people are
already here at bob price park here in
the northeast valley police are actually
here behind me setting up some food
there's hot dogs a lot of snacks and
there's a lot of community partners out
here as well with tents set up as far as
i can see really here in the park and if
you look further back there you got some
bouncy houses for a lot of the kids out
here and along with all the fun and food
national night out is really a way to
build partnerships between metro police
and the public it's designed to raise
awareness about crime and drug
prevention through support for
anti-crime programs and show the
community how to protect their
neighborhoods you're hearing all that
applause after the national anthem just
wrapped up here the latest numbers from
metro show that murders rapes and car
thefts are up in the northeast area
compared to this time last year that's
why people here tonight tell us nights
like this can make all the difference
the more that police can get out and
build that stronger relationship and
same with the community get out and
build that um just having kind of a
stronger community and base
just takes away crime as well
so obviously that's the one of the main
goals here of national night out but
also just to have fun and get to know
the police officers in the community
everything at this event is free and
there's a whole lot of entertainment out
here to just take a look at that stage
national night out here this event in
the northeast at bob price park will
continue until 8 o'clock tonight
reporting live in the northeast valley
orca mana live local now